[Music]
this weekend
as any Marvel fan will tell you is all
about the endgame
Avengers endgame will wrap up the
massive cliffhanger from last year's
infinity war and a warning we won't be
spoiling in-game but we will be
discussing a number of Marvel's movies
up to this point now this isn't just
about whether cap Iron Man and the rest
of the team will be able to bring back
their fallen comrades because over 21
movies the Marvel Cinematic Universe has
actually raised a number of thorny
questions teaching us about ethics
leadership and even moral philosophy
even if there's a small chance that we
can undo this I mean we owe it to
everyone who's not in this room to try
and that's where Chris Robicheaux comes
in I'm a senior lecturer in ethics and
public policy here at the Harvard
Kennedy School and I'm also a lifelong
fan of superheroes and comic books and
comic book stories so let's get right to
it then with the Avengers what what
makes them interesting one of the things
I really love about the Avengers that
we've seen now over over multiple movies
is believe it or not their dysfunction
you know and and by this I mean you know
individually here are these amazing
superheroes and we've seen their stories
their individual stories and then Nick
Fury early on says hey you know I've got
this idea you know bringing together an
ensemble of extraordinary people to do
you know extraordinary things the idea
was to see if they could become
something more see if they could work
together when we needed them to to fight
the battles that we never could they
don't often succeed what they do and I
think that's important I think it's
important for us to see that just
because you've got a lot of power
doesn't mean that it's automatically
going to succeed in staving off the bat
by the time we get to infinity war I
mean they're all over the place they're
not communicating with each other you
know they're literally not talking to
each other they're going offline where
this huge threat is coming and not just
a threat to the earth but to the
universe so what's at the root of this
dysfunction is this difference in
leadership or is this something more
fundamental is this a different moral
outlook part of it is who actually is is
leading the Avengers right so they're
sort of vying for the leadership
to fight Tony you just started a war you
know we've seen over the course of these
movies they're really starting to
approach their mission in fundamentally
different ways I was wrong about you the
whole world was wrong about you there's
this amazing scene in in Captain America
Civil War where they're considering you
know the the idea of being watched by
the US and we see them torn apart in
part for philosophical reasons so Tony
Stark
iron man who was almost always full of
his of himself and his ego and convinced
that he's got the righteous path' he's
the one that's like you know hmm
maybe we ought to have some oversight we
have no decision-making procedure in
this team we need to be put in check
whatever form that takes I'm game if we
can't accept limitations we're bound
realist for no better than the bad guys
similarly Captain America it's the guy
who's supposed to stand for democracy
was like I don't know if we should hand
our authority over to a deliberative
body if we sign this we surrender our
right to choose what if this panel sends
us somewhere we don't think we should go
what if there's somewhere we need to go
and they don't let us we may not be
perfect but the safest hands are still
our own if we don't do this now it's
gonna be done to us later that to me
makes them a very interesting team to
watch they have not yet assemble it
feels like that has such ready
comparison to so many real-world
conversations in that vein what do you
find the easiest parallels with it's not
that Steve and Tony are disagreeing and
one of them is a lunatic and the other
one is the voice of reason
right both of them have reasonable
positions on things that's something
that I see show up a lot in the American
context and elsewhere our disagreements
at times we're terrible at treating our
opponents we disagree with respectfully
sit down final warning
have you do this holiday but often the
disagreement is a reasonable one people
just prioritize different things you
know they emphasize Liberty more they
emphasize equality more the entire
Marvel Cinematic Universe is very much a
post-911 universe and it's in one of its
central questions as to what extent
should safety and security Trump
individual privacy and part of that
conversation as to what extent should
democratic institutions make these
decisions versus behind closed doors
government agents or private
organizations I'm not looking for
forgiveness and I'm Way past asking
permission earth just lost your best
defender so we're here to fight and if
you want to stand in our way we'll fight
you too so let's jump from what are
usually our earthbound heroes the
Avengers out into space - to another
team - the Guardians
audience what's what's the difference
here they seem to run very very
differently The Avengers are team and
they're struggling to become a
functional team the guardians of the
galaxy are family but it's a chosen
family they've chosen each other but but
we can see the idea of them being a
family sort of putting up with each
other's you know flaws and insecurities
Groot is the baby
turn teenager by the time we have
infinity war group hey they work
together I think because they have a
kind of family relationship man muscular
man a muscular who you kiddin well
you're one sandwich away from fat yeah
right it's true you know they're
responding to this you know crisis
signal in the midst of trying to figure
out what the heck's going on there
there's all of this like back and forth
you know there's the jealousy of
star-lord
there's Drax saying you know you've put
on some weight it's like what would
happen in a family you know you're in
the presence of a god and meanwhile
they're talking about the whether
there's been weight gain or not I'm
gonna commit I'm gonna get some
dumbbells with infinity war we're
talking about a threat on an entirely
different scale
Thanos wants to eradicate half the
universe but he's also rationalized this
to himself
as a good thing 20 mouths enough to go
around
and when we faced extinction I offered a
solution
genocide but random his passion is fair
to rich and poor alike so what what
makes this different than just
straight-up genocide so if I could frame
this you know in in philosophical terms
Thanos has sort of a pure
consequentialist he was sacrificed any
individual including his beloved
daughter for the sake of pursuing the
grade is good I didn't or death Denis
once I cannot do that again even
for you I think there's something deep
here because Thanos sees himself as
being quite rational many people think
the consequentialism taken to its
logical conclusion can be quite horrific
because it fails to take into account
the individual a lot of our heroes are
fancy term coming deontologists they
believe that you know the greatest good
is not always the thing that we should
keep in mind we should keep cherish
relationships and individuals the heroes
regularly do not put the greatest good
above any individual Captain America has
that great line nots threatens half the
universe one life cannot stand in the
way of defeating him but it should we
don't trade lies what happened to the
the nihilist villain what happened to
the bad guy that just wanted to watch
the world burn everyone has to have
these grand aspirations and these
reasons for doing these horrific things
why nihilism I think is a hard thing for
us to wrap our heads around at times
because we always think we always think
that there's got to be reasons other
than to watch the world burn but it is
more helpful I think for us to sort of
sympathize sympathize with characters if
we can get around our heads around an
agenda that they have that at least
seems reasonable it's just more
interesting to engage a villain who
isn't just a cardboard cutout I view
this all as a warning to us Thanos and a
sense says look here's my reasoning is
reasoning a seductive you planet was on
the brink of collapse
I'm the one who stopped that
you know what's happened since then the
children born have known nothing but
full bellies and clear skies it's a
paradise
because you have to plan it small price
to pay for salvation and it's an
invitation for us to say look there's
something to what Thanos says but we
don't want to end up like vanos so where
do we stop ourselves so it makes for
great personal reflection too I think
and as you said that insistence that
this is all for a greater good tends to
blur the lines between good and evil in
characters that we have previously
placed on one side of that divide and
you name Loki and and nebula those are
two great examples what does that tell
us and the fan reaction to characters
like this about the way we prize that
moral ambiguity that finding good in the
bad or finding that in the good yeah I
think that you know Marvel superheroes
stories on cinema have given us an
opportunity to recognize that heroism
does not come in the sense of you're
always righteous and perfect and making
the right choice it's an invitation for
us to look inward and realize look a lot
of this is gray people that we care
about who are aiming at the good
sometimes fail I feel like this is
empowering in its own way because it's
telling us you don't have to have it all
figured out
a lot of the world doesn't come in black
and white but that doesn't mean you
should stop aiming and doing good things
and even our heroes are not perfect and
do fail and have disagreements and
they're still trying to bring about good
in the world and even our villains
there's something to what they're saying
even though they've clearly gone around
the bend let's go to Captain Marvel for
a second the movie not the character
because that was kind of a different
sort of conflict at its heart this is a
generational struggle between two alien
races prove you not a Skrull
what does the kree-skrull war tell us
about power one thing it invites us to
do is to not assume that we have figured
out who the good people are and the bad
people are based on the initial framing
of things early on and Captain Marvel
the Kree are good the scroll are bad and
you know the scroll perfectly fit the
bad paradigm is they're they're shifty
literally the shapeshifters you know but
I I think the movie apart is saying to
us you know not everything is what it
seems
indeed so much of Captain Marvel's about
not everything is what it seems
and maybe you should get to know the
supposed enemy a little bit more before
passing judgments about that I don't
hear Captain Marvel is giving us some
some lame story where everyone's really
good at the end that's not there's not
the case it's just it's more complicated
and I think that that's an important
lesson and Captain Marvel herself the
character not the movie is immensely
powerful perhaps more powerful than than
any hero we've seen so far
she and Thanos wield their power so
differently and and what is having that
much power mean one of the things I love
about superhero stories is their stories
of empowerment and the Captain Marvel
story that we got in in this movie is a
classic example about this you know for
good chunk of the movie
she doesn't remember exactly who she is
and she's got all these people telling
her who she is and she's like alright
alright and it's only towards the end
when she literally takes off you know
the thing that's been binding her and
constraining her and she embraces her
power that that we we see Carol Danvers
becoming you know Captain Marvel and
then she creates an unbelievable weapon
creating a whole bunch of havoc for for
the creek
we know that power corrupts and so we
hope that Captain Marvel can not become
corrupted the thing that's interesting
is we don't know
kurz is going to be a path of wrestling
with tremendous tremendous power an
ongoing lesson for us that power can
corrupt and we really haven't seen that
yet in the MCU which is focusing on a
hero who is grappling with the effect of
their enormous power on their personal
not just philosophy but their morality
and it would seem that that's a that's a
fascinating place to go in the future I
think it has to go there in the future
you know I mean in many ways we've seen
these characters dealing with their
power and dealing with the the perhaps
accidental misuse of it but we really
haven't seen too much I think in the
cinematic universe as you said with the
corrupting influence of power
I guess the MCU can do everything in in
a mere 10 years with a with a mere 20
some movies I'm glad that's the story
still to be told
yeah what's up guys obviously there's
the old chestnut from spider-man
what other responsibilities do the
powerful have I think that one of the
most recent movies that has explored
this in quite an interesting ways black
benefit so you know Black Panther has
this amazing exchange
halfway 2/3 through it as kill monger
comes to Wakanda and he sort of throws
down it's about two billion people all
over the world it looks like us but
their lives are a lot harder makanda has
the tools to liberate them all and what
taught us of us vibranium your weapons
our weapons will not be used to wage war
on the world it is not our way and what
the movie challenges us to consider and
again this is a great idea of the
villain is you know there's something to
that kill monger isn't entirely off is
this a responsible use of power is
fighting injustice in this way a good
use of the power that you have
that's an interesting philosophical
disagreement and so I give to the the
credit of the Black Panther into the
we'll universe at least asking those
questions what does responsible use of
power look like there's never one answer
to that a lot of people find distinction
between the MCU and DC Universe
Cinematic Universe even though they
don't call it that through visual means
and like what the directorial
sensibility is but it seems like there's
something much more fundamental at play
as well how would you mark that
distinction between the ethos of the two
universes
I think Marvel sort of takes it for
granted that there are these existential
threats to humanity and is looking more
at how individuals who have the capacity
to do something should conduct
themselves in sort of you know attending
to this so there's some overlap there
but I don't see there to be tremendous
tension in the Marvel Universe with with
what DC is looking at as you know the
relationship with the people
[Music]
we don't get that we get a Superman in
Man of Steel who's like you know I don't
know if I should like reveal my powers
or if I should mean his dad in that
movie quite remarkably too many people
has this conversation with his son when
his son saves the bus of kids being like
yeah I don't know if you know that that
was the right time to do it and you know
a Clark young Clark Kent's like but I
can save them said I don't know if you
should save them or not what was I
supposed to do just let them die
maybe Wonder Woman uh which I adore this
movie right Wonder Woman at some point
realizes you know it's not Ares that's
causing humanity to fight each other
it's humanity causing humanity to fight
each other they can stop fighting man
why are they still because I think
that's because mate maybe it's them
maybe maybe people aren't always good is
there anything here like worth doing and
so there's this a really complicated
relationship I see in the DC Universe at
least in those examples I've given
between the heroes and the people that
they're trying to be heroic for I don't
see nearly as much as that in in in
Marvel and so I think that there's a
richness there in the DC movies despite
the fact that often they do they do
sometimes fail on their own terms and
they're darker than what a lot of people
want and in Marvel not necessarily
grapping grappling with those individual
questions is much more concerned with
with what I think that one of the things
that Marvel does a great job of
exploring is broken people can have
power flawed people can have power let's
look at them wrestle with how to do good
given their power but also their flawed
natures we're not a team we're a time
bomb
superhero stories in general this is a
theme that I've often I've often talked
about have a good side and a bad side
the good side is they often give us
stories about individuals being
empowered and trying to do good and they
sort of inspire us to do that the bad
side is that they sometimes create the
impression that if you're just a good
person you will do good things and we
know that that's not true and so I see
that in a lot of the movies that we're
looking at this theme of well what
happens if someone with power who's not
good gets in control comes again and
again
T'Challa sits on the throne of Wakanda
great what what do people do when it's
come Ungar who sits on the throne nah
omnia - would we trust Captain America
with the Infinity Gauntlet I bet you a
lot of people be like yes
should you I don't know it can be it can
ruin people I think that that theme
resonates very much with our political
moment is that we see that you can just
because you have power doesn't mean one
that you're good and even if you are
good having a lot of power means that
you might use it in untoward ways and so
I see us trying to work this out in our
superhero stores excellent well have a
great day
thanks so much
[Music]
you